hi hi it's John here with a very special
coal to open so during this episode of
dear Hank and John Hank and I talked
quite a bit about his upcoming book an
absolutely remarkable thing we also
mentioned that the pre-order will be
available soon well every time we say
that just imagine that we are actually
saying the pre-order is available now
that's right Hanks book is available for
pre-order now wherever you pre-order
books you can also go to Hank green comm
there are links there ok that's it I
just wanted to pre correct to the
incorrect facts in this pod also I just
want to say this is a really really
wonderful book I'm not saying that only
because Hank is my brother it is a
really special novel I am so proud of
him and so excited for him I really hope
that you'll pre-order the book it's
called an absolutely remarkable thing
it's by Hank green it is his first novel
and it is available for pre-order now
all right on to the episode hello and
welcome to this weekend - that's not the
title of this podcast at all
that's it I prefer to think of it as
Dear John and Hank or this weekend
Ryan's whatever it's a comedy podcast
where two brothers answer your question
ubw surprised to bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John how are you I'm cold I'm
cold Hank I've been cold for two months
it's complete this situation is utterly
unacceptable to me every day I go
outside and it is somehow colder than it
was the day before the snow is so cold
you can't even make snowballs out of it
it just falls apart in your hands
because it's made out of ice it's ice
snow yeah oh no horrible horrible
everything is terrible I'm so tired of
winter why do I live here I mean I like
I didn't even know that Indianapolis
really had winter I mean Julie has a
nice mild winter where it gets down to
you know like ten degrees a few times
this the entire month of January has
been just horrific terrible so I just
want to say to everybody and warm
weather climates if you're listening to
this in the southern hemisphere if
you're in Florida or Arizona or
something
I just just give us a bit of that warmth
we're desperate up here we're dying Oh
Chuck so so what do you say that
things that are sort of like native to
Indianapolis yeah
weather clearly is not one of them that
you really enjoy also I don't see you
going out to sort of like the tremendous
variety of chain restaurants that are
available to you you don't seem to be
indulging in that sort of like which is
that which is a big perk of Indianapolis
you do you do enjoy the Motor Speedway
so maybe it's that like the thing that's
keeping you there what is it about
Indianapolis like of the things that are
specific to that place that you're
really is sort of indulge in I love the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway
but you really only need the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway one day a
year you know and I could probably fall
in like if necessary I could probably
fly in for the race what happens is
they're like do they have an
amphitheater or do they have like go the
whole months racing actually the whole
month of May in Indianapolis is a great
thrill because the cars are running
almost everyday you can take your kids
to the garage that can meet the drivers
they can see all the engineering and
stuff and that's fun other than that the
main thing that keeps me here is the
people which sounds I know a little bit
cheesy but it's true we have wonderful
friends and the thought of moving to a
different place where I would have to
make new friends just is unbearable to
me it took me so long to make good
friends and then I have to say I find it
to be a physically beautiful place much
of the year so that even though I'm only
you know 8 or 10 minutes away from the
11th largest downtown in the United
States so it's a properly big city I get
to live with coyotes and foxes and deer
and all that stuff so that's the other
big thing that I like about it but it's
no Missoula Hank I'll tell you that it's
noticing yeah that comes to coal what
are the what are the things that are
specific to Indianapolis that you choose
not to indulge in like in Missoula I
choose not to indulge in in like
downhill skiing oh yeah it is not
suitable for my temperament right no
mine neither I'm not a downhill skier or
snowboarder for that matter the main
thing that I choose not to indulge in in
Indianapolis is the sports there's a
tremendous sporting culture here for the
Indianapolis Colts Indianapolis Pacers
and it's just like it's not that I don't
like the Colts I know a couple of the
cults some of them may be listening
they're nice I know I do I do a hello
cult I have a couple cult friends it's
like is one cult a cult like if you're
just like one of the Broncos you're a
Bronco oh yeah one of the Lakers you're
a Laker yeah yeah it works okay I have
to say the two cults I know the best I'm
not sure that they're completely
committed to being Indianapolis Colts so
much as they enjoy being in the NFL the
overwhelming draw so much that being
able to play professional football but
yeah anyway I don't I guess that's what
I don't indulge in would you like a
short poem yeah hit me all right it's
way it's fire and ice by Robert Frost
you know this you know this poem is
Robert Frost his actual last name frost
I think so yeah that's but that's why I
went with it because we've got a cold
theme yeah fire and ice
emphasis on the ice poem goes like this
some say the world will end in fire some
say in ice from what I've tasted of
desire I hold with those who favor fire
but if it had to perish twice I think I
know enough of hate to say that for
Destruction ice is also great than would
suffice mmm nice poem by Robert Frost
about Fire and Ice and hate and God it's
so cold
do you know how many Pulitzer Prizes
Robert Frost one two four also Silla his
last name isn't actually Frost his name
is Robert Lee Ryan no no no you can't
catch me you can't you can't trick me
with Ryan jokes I'm - I'm - ready for
them Hank let's nice to answer some
questions from our listeners this first
question comes from on hill who asks
dear Hank and John I have some novels I
want to recommend to this person but
we're not really close and he isn't even
a reader I think that he'll really like
these novels but I can't come up to him
and be like hey you don't know me but
here's that book read it read it read it
how do I approach him suddenly and segue
into giving him recommendations and
actually get this person to read the
books hoping for you to be his advice I
mean it's a great question for me
because of course
my career is literally built around
trying to get people I don't know to
read a book
whatever I was at Barnes and Noble and
there is somebody who who had picked up
The Fault in Our Stars and they were
like looking at it and like going and
like they walked around the store for a
little bit and then they put it back and
I was like what do I do in this
situation do I just let this happen do I
just let the not by The Fault in Our
Stars who was clearly considering it but
has now made the ultimate decision that
no instead I'm going to buy some other
piece of trash no I'm good but it is it
is difficult I think you if you're going
to intervene in that situation Hank you
have to do it before they put the book
down so you have to be like while
they're holding it you have to be like
oh that's a great book I really really
enjoyed it I certainly do that whenever
I'm in target and I see somebody holding
Turtles all the way down I'm always like
hey I think you like that I really loved
it I think it's better if they put it
back on the shelf and then I grab it and
I'm like run up to them I like you you
you put this down you lost this you
forgot it and they'll be like no I meant
now like no no it's yours now your hands
are all over it until the thing you have
to do is you have to become closer to
this person I mean you can't just go
forcing media on people you don't know
well because you think that they'll like
it you have to develop a relationship
and then voice to the media yep yeah I
have no idea I have a very hard time
getting people to read books because
books are a big commitment and and
people also have a hard time getting me
to read books you sent me some books for
Christmas and I haven't read any of them
yet no there's a couple really good ones
I'll do my best
I'm in the middle of so many different
books John hey Hank
king of books when is your book gonna be
available for pre-order so I can start
talking about it I don't know the answer
to that question John but it should be
relatively soon it's so good I mean I
admittedly I to be honest I did go into
it with somewhat low expectations
[Laughter]
okay so it was so much better than I
expected it to be tell me about your low
expectations let's start there
well you know I've read a lot of books
by youtubers Oh some of them are great
some of them are terrible so you know I
went into it thinking oh great another
youtuber book just what the world needs
but it's brilliant Thanks
I really is I mean I'm not just saying
that I was completely and the thing
about it I won't go I won't go into it
too much because like we got to save the
praise for when people can pre-order but
the thing about it that has really stuck
with me is that it is uh it is a it is a
really fascinating exploration of how
Fame and the culture around Fame warps
individual consciousnesses but also it
is a incredibly well told story like my
books are mostly about how plot gets
interrupted by character and your book
is so well plotted like it was such a
pleasure to read I roared I roared
through it so anyway I'm incredibly
excited for you and and and really
genuinely blown away by how good it is
thank you thank you a lot the thing that
that we're working on right now is the
is that the copy that's gonna like like
the pre-order will go up but there's all
the like words that go up like in his
much-anticipated debut novel Hank green
is has a book spins a sweeping cinematic
tale about a young woman who becomes an
overnight sensation and realizes that
she's part of something bigger than
anyone could possibly imagine
of reading directly off of the thing
right now and yeah and and so I have to
like figure out what that's going to
look like I mean I have to approve these
words I never thought about the fact
that like I didn't think I'd be involved
in that process
oh yeah no there's a lot of authoring
that that you don't know about yet um
there's a lot of making sausage in any
business and then when you're actually
making the sausage you're like oh this
is a lot of work isn't it yep yep all
right let's move all doing adequate
agreat this sausage crank yeah exactly
go a good luck cranking the flap copy
sauce
crank that's what that's called by the
way the flap copy always liked that term
alright this next question comes from
Olivia who writes Dear John and Hank is
Kylie Jenner pregnant I have no idea
what conclusions to draw from the
available evidence which is mostly
reports from anonymous sources and
insiders and I have no idea what that
means it's driving me crazy which is a
situation I never expected to be and I
appreciate your dubious thoughts on all
subjects including hopefully this one
Olivia
John I mean it does seem that we know a
surprising amount about Kylie Jenner's
reproductive strategies considering that
she has not said anything about this
publicly and so I feel like it's none of
my business whether kylie jenner is
pregnant yeah yeah no I agree
obviously it's none of our business but
I and my initial feeling was also like
oh this question it's unfair it's unfair
to Kylie etc but then I am completely
obsessed with other unanswered questions
like whether Donald Trump knowingly
colluded with the Russian government
during his campaign for president which
is also a question that will be answered
in the fullness of time and I argue is
like maybe the question itself is more
important than the question of whether
Kylie Jenner is pregnant but the way
that I am interested in it is in that
exact same salacious way that one is
interested in any piece of gossip so I
don't want to be dismissive of the
question I will say Kylie Jenner had a
crib delivered to her home in Los
Angeles recently which i think is highly
dubious is there a certain well I mean
sometimes your your friends are coming
over and they have kids or you're you
know her her sisters I can play in that
situation I'm not wholly free well if
you're really rich you probably do you
probably have smoking it's like a bunch
of extra rooms in our house uh Kylie
Jenner is that that rich I think that
Kylie Jenner is probably rich I just
assumed I'd hear her name a lot I think
that she has a makeup line oh oh oh
she's she's very rich
did you do google Kylie Jenner net worth
like everybody else in the world I did I
did I did Kylie Jenner is a wealthy
person oh there's no way that Kylie
Jenner is as rich as it says she is but
she is very well-off yeah oh I'm happy
for is the important thing I'm sure she
works hard and if she whether or not
she's pregnant is not our business and
she will tell us when she is ready it's
weird because of course like we all feel
like we deserve some kind of access to
celebrities lives because they do offer
us access to their lives right but I
also think that people should be able to
draw the line where they want to draw it
yeah but I do I do feel like like is
there if there a possibility that kylie
jenner is like intentionally getting a
crib delivered to her home in order to
create more news around kylie jenner
that she's going to CVS and a large
hoodie and which could be concealed a
baby bump in order to generate more buzz
about kylie jenner it seems maybe seems
like maybe I don't know I mean the this
is actually this gets back to issues
raised in your book it's in fascinating
ways we do as public figures and by the
way like I don't think you and I are
alternative at different from kylie
jenner except in terms of scale and also
success she's been far more but but III
I think people are are inevitably to an
extent calculating about the way that
the public looks at them I'm not sure
that they're that calculating yeah yeah
I don't know I think that I think that
isn't an unknowable thing and it's just
kind of another thing that we can talk
about and and we'll talk about and like
that can generate more discussion and
like it's very interesting that that
even that discussion is part of that
feedback loop right so one thing that we
all definitely know not just the
Jenner's and Kardashian's of the world
but all of us is that speculation is
more valuable than fact so the
speculation over whether Kylie Jenner is
pregnant is certainly taking up a lot
more space right
and ultimately the fact will yes yep
this next question comes from Brooke who
asks dear Hank and John I've been
friends with this guy for six years and
I assumed that I knew most things about
him that could affect our friendship
however the other day we were driving
around and he pulls over finishes his
drink and throws the cup out the window
no boy we became friends because we
share the same sense of humor along with
pretty similar core beliefs and values
but I do not know how to react to this
realization that my best friend
apparently now this is your best friend
and my best friend willingly litters
without remorse should I just accept him
as he is or try to explain how I feel
about this possibly creating an awkward
situation where I come off his
self-righteous any dubious advice would
be appreciated best wishes Brooke how do
you even watch this occur without saying
something yeah I feel like that's when
you say like stop the car walk back to
the car ha ha ha pick up the cup walk
back to the car
apologize write a letter to your local I
like you know it's wrapping the horse
saying that you're sorry and you've done
this in the past and you've changed your
ways yeah I mean we all do terrible
things Hank look we're all deeply flawed
people we're all contributing to
systemic injustice but you don't have to
throw a cup out the window for God's
sakes I mean there's trash cans at every
place they're all over ya and there's a
whole car of places to put a cup that's
what I was thinking forget about trash
cans my feeling is that my car is a
large trash can and then just
periodically I take out a trash yeah
yeah no I can I can I can confirm that
that is how you feel about your car the
the thing that I wonder is like is there
a universe in which Brookes friend
thinks that Brooke now thinks he's
cooler because of his irreverent
disregard for
littering right maybe I'm just right
look at me I'm just like I I the the
system just doesn't just the system Wow
the rules don't apply to me rage against
them I'm selfish man yeah that's right
well I'm not Jewish man you're sticking
it to probably just all the people who
now have to look at you the trash on the
side of the road
I also the people who have to clean it
up which yeah I think in generously like
I want to have a relationship with my
friends where when they do something
that I think is just unacceptable I can
be like dude that is unacceptable and
totally so that would be my bigger
concern Brooke is not so much that this
person did this although it is duly
horrifying but more that the question of
do you feel comfortable confronting them
and saying like oh come on
yeah because usually you should if this
is your best friend if you've been
friends with this person for six years
you should be in that place where you
can not have to worry about coming off a
self-righteous and of course like not
everybody has the same level of
self-confidence and and and power in a
relationship but but I think that that
is a completely normal thing for a
friend
to do and I would not it's weird now
because you didn't do it in the moment
and it would be like okay do we have to
talk about one time I did this with a
friend of mine who like who like we
split the check and then like it became
clear that he did not live leave a tip
and I was like do I and I didn't say
anything in the moment and then I was
like but now I want to like make sure
that he knows that what the rules are
cuz like there's rules and maybe he
didn't learn the rules but also maybe he
thought because we were splitting the
check that it was different somehow and
so I ended up having the conversation
and then he lied to me about it
he just lied he was like no no I always
leave a tip and and then I was like oh I
think that you're not a good guy mmm
yeah maybe maybe he was just embarrassed
and maybe that's how he deals with
embarrassment am i as you know Hank I'm
a little more sympathetic to Liars than
you are
I don't know why I think it's just
because I'm a more generous empathetic
person yeah uh-huh yeah yeah I'm gonna
tell you a story about my dirty car okay
is it true it's true it's true I don't
even I don't know if it's funny I I do
know that I think about it all the time
though I think about it it said almost
every single time I get into my car so
many years ago when I was living in
Chicago and when Sara and I were first
dating we I was still living with my
buddy Hasan and Hasan and Sarah and I
were walking up to my car and Hassan
said every time I approach your car I
always expect to be there to be a little
rat sitting in the passenger seat hold
clutching of purse and looking up at me
and saying where are we going today and
my cars are still filthy and every
single time every single time I walk up
to the car I think like is the little
rat we're clutching the first gonna be
here today yes like the rat is so at
home basically you have become like
Driving Miss rat right exactly
all right this next question comes from
Natalie who writes dear John and Hank if
someone stole a bass clarinet from my
high school and gave it to me do I have
a moral obligation to return it
the band director didn't even notice it
was gone and the girl who stole it
graduated Natalie I feel like we're
going over some real basic stuff today
John yeah we hoard stolen goods I mean
this is Natalie you got it you got to
return the bass clarinet in this
situation a hundred times out of 100 I'm
sorry the only way in which maybe you
don't have to return the bass clarinet
is if you paid for it
not knowing that it was stolen and later
found out it was story that is an
interesting dilemma yeah this is not an
interesting moral dilemma no yeah I'm
afraid I'm afraid whether or not the
stolen property has been identified as
stolen and also do you know that the
director didn't notice it was gone or
does the band director tell you about
all of the things that get stolen like
are you on like the band director email
list I'm still like that where their
communications with the police like you
don't know also in a way isn't it worse
if the band director didn't notice it
was stolen because it just means the
band director is so downtrodden about
the amount of stolen goods flying out of
the band room oh man listen Natalie the
great thing about your situation is that
you can be a hero here you walk into the
band director's office say I have two
pieces of good news I did not steal this
bass clarinet which you can say in
complete honesty however I am returning
it to you because the person who did
steal it graduated and gave it to me and
I didn't feel right about it so here it
is PS if you want to give me a reward
for my generosity a bass clarinet would
be a great reward and so maybe you've
got like a 5% chance of getting right
you know a guilt-free bass clarinet and
also PPS no I cannot tell you who stole
the bass clarinet I'm sorry if that
person is my friend right yeah you can't
you say I'm not gonna name names but
they did graduate and then maybe you
give give them a couple hints this next
question comes from M who asks dear Hank
and John is it impolite to move when a
smoker sits down next to you currently
at the library at a computer and
somebody came in smelling a lot like
cigarette smoking I can't just leave
because I need to use the computers but
I please help I have tried to stop
breathing and it is not going well I
await your answer M yeah you could
totally move I do that I get a movie
theater if I bump somebody who sits down
next menu smells a lot like cigarette
smoke I will move absolutely so there's
broadly speaking two kinds of former
smokers there's the kind who can no
longer bear the sight or cigarettes or
the smell of cigarette smoke or the
smell of you know a person's jacket
after they've smoked cigarettes and I am
NOT that kind of ex mocker I am the kind
of ex mocker who if somebody sits down
next to me and even if it is the most
rancid
stale cigarette smoke
smell I'll just be like cotillion over
here a little bit yeah yeah it's just
like the best perfume in the world to me
and when people smoke near me I other
people who like get up and move and I'll
be like I'm sorry if it's okay with you
guys I'm gonna stay here and enjoy the
secondhand smoke because it's as good as
it gets for me these days oh man I never
smoked so I have not that person
III will even move if like somebody's
like vaping nearby no they don't move
because I I don't like to see people
vaping near me because the problem with
the vaping is that I can see the cloud
it's not the smell or anything it's that
I can see the cloud of their breath
approaching me yeah that's like so
horrifying to me because I know all of
the bacteria that are traveling with
their vapes motor silverwares me these
like they're shooting me these these
rings of vape and I'm just like oh god
no yeah because there's there's
something about cigarette smoke where
some of it's coming out of the lungs and
some of its come into the cigarette and
see you like no hundred percent that
like you don't know a hundred percent
where the smoke has been maybe it's just
exactly but if it's vape smoke a hundred
percent of that vape smoke has been
inside a person yeah no that's just
breath visualized it's terrible now that
you said it it's breath visualized one -
I can't help but trying to guess what
flavour the vape juice is oh that's that
leads to like like suddenly all
conversation stops and you're like is it
like peppermint banana what is God is it
good is that it's not like Jolly Rancher
watermelon flavor or or is it how what
is that clove what's happening to my
nose and you can never quite figure out
and you have to go talk to the strange
vapor and be like what is it just tell
me what is the juice you got in there
bud I can't believe I I mean I would
think that you're doing a bit except you
are the kind of person to walk up to a
stranger and say what is the flavor of
your vape juice
I totally am you really are it's
distressing to me like that's that we
share so much DNA and yet you're willing
to do a thing that I wouldn't do for
like probably low five figures alright
this next question comes from Aida who
writes Dear John and Hank are fogs
clouds and if so can they rain does
everything just get wet what about
lightening water is weird
ada our fogs clouds John our fogs clap
well but ok I'm not a scientist but my
inclination is to believe that fogs are
essentially extremely low hanging clouds
yeah well so like the weird thing is
what it what where does a cloud become
clouds like if if you got one of those
days where it's just a hundred percent
gray above you is that just one cloud
it's cloudy right but but those aren't
clouds because they're not integrated
from each other so fog is one cloud kind
of weirdly definitionally like you are
like fog is when you are inside of a
single cloud and then so yes it is a
cloud it's not clouds but would be if
you looked at a bunch of different fog
from far away and it's like clouds
hitting the land but what I have never
heard of yeah I mean the reason I and I
think that there's a good reason for
this it's like fog clouds form in a
different way than like cumulonimbus
clouds do and so they don't have as much
perturbation and they don't have as much
they're not as much like energy in them
so they can't they're not big enough to
create lightning so you shouldn't have
to worry about fog lightning though now
that I've said it out loud I the world
is a large place and maybe fog lightning
has happened somewhere but fog but fog
clouds do rain you will notice that if
you ever lived in the Pacific Northwest
where you'll be like it's foggy and
think of like it's raining and foggy
what is this dis disgusting I hate it
but I don't think that you have to worry
about fog lightning I don't think
so I once walked through a cloud while
descending a mountain in Denali National
Park in Alaska with a girl who'd broken
up with me like two weeks before but for
some reason we decided to continue on
this trip uh-huh it's not totally
relevant to the story but my experience
walking through an actual cloud was that
it was somewhat thicker than walking
through most fogs are I mean I think
that it comes down to the fogs John
there's a lot of different fogs
sometimes they're pretty thin sometimes
they're extremely thick yeah okay well
I'll believe you but I don't think I
think that fog lightning is something
that we are relatively safe from this
next question John comes from Christine
who asks dear Hank and John I work as a
volunteer at the local food bank I love
my work we help over 450 families in our
city alone I see those families
registered them and check their finances
every few months about half of our
clients are Dutch I'm from the
Netherlands people with huge debt
problems and the other half are refugees
who recently got their status as a
refugee and are waiting for their
financial situation to be fixed by the
government well I don't know well I know
that my work is appreciated and many
many people depend on it I have found
some strange things people do which
should expel them from our food aid like
only taking a few items out of the whole
crate of food we provide them or
spending all their money at a casino the
strange thing is that this hasn't
happened to any of our Dutch clients
this combined with the fact that many of
our immigrant clients don't speak Dutch
or English or German or French and I
don't speak Turkish or Arabic has made
me think a bit weirdly of our non Dutch
clients I'm not the only one my
colleagues who have been doing this for
many years vote the anti-immigration
party how do I make sure that I don't
become a racist when I have so many bad
experiences with immigrants I like
thinking that everything is nuanced but
it's getting hard loving food Christine
I thought this is a really interesting
question Hank and it's a difficult one
the first thing I wanted to say about it
is that I don't think racism is only a
character flaw it is also structural it
is also you know like built into built
into political and social and economic
systems and so I think it's important to
remember that the second thing I wanted
to say is that it's really difficult but
in
incredibly important to be empathetic to
people's experiences and how difficult
and experience it is to be a refugee and
sometimes people are going to deal with
that poorly and they're going to make
really bad choices people are gonna be
as human as anyone else except the
population that you're working with
Christine in many cases are people who
have survived what is to me unimaginable
trauma they've survived the trauma of
dislocation in many cases they've
survived the kinds of loss that most of
us will never have to imagine and now
they're in a place that feels very
distant from the way that they have
lived before and that's challenging and
one of the ways you might deal with that
for instance is to not eat a lot of the
food because a lot of the food isn't
good to you or it doesn't make sense to
you or you don't know how to prepare it
and because you can't have the
conversations that you need to have to
build that empathy to bridge that
empathy gap because of language all of
these problems I think can compound upon
each other so just as you're struggling
to empathize with people who maybe are
making bad choices or in other cases or
maybe just dealing with the regular
traumas and dislocations of being a
refugee you have to also remember that
in a lot of cases the people you're
working with can't communicate
effectively with people who are the
people who would be giving them services
and help and for instance helping them
with a gambling addiction and so I think
you have to work to bridge that empathy
gap now that work goes both ways the
refugee populations also need to work to
bridge the empathy gap in their host
countries and so I I don't want to say
that all of the work lives with you but
I do think that it has to be to agree
the the thing that I had I thought that
was great John is also like that racism
like judging people based on the way
that they look at the width
like these that this is a natural thing
that happens to people we are pattern
recognition machines and and when you
when you are having you know a number of
interactions and some of them are
negative and then some of them end up
being negative with person who looks one
way more than a person who looks another
way you start to apply that sort of like
that one negative thing to all of the
people because you maybe only interact
with people in a certain circumstance
and so it becomes pretty easy to start
to see things in a blanket way when they
aren't actual like when they when they
actually aren't a blanket way but right
but I think that it's like the the
remarkable thing Christine is like how
like carefully you're thinking about
this and and also how hard you're
working to serve the people that you
serve and thank you for doing that and
and I'm glad that the Netherlands has
support systems for its citizens both
people who have been there a while and
for the refugees as well yeah for sure
all right let's get to one more question
before we thank our sponsors this one
comes from Jessica who writes dear John
and Hank about a month ago I got a new
job with my local Girl Scout Council and
while the job is fulfilling there is one
problem I thought there would be more
cookies
no one has offered me cookies however
there is a cookie closet filled with
several cases each kind of cookie the
problem is that oh my god to gain access
to the cookie closet I must tell the
secretary why I need cookies any dubious
advice and fake reasons are appreciated
cookies and conundrums Jessica well when
this question started out I thought that
the the thing was gonna be like I
thought there would be more cookies but
it turns out that we only have cookie
that we like people order the cookie
know there is a cookie the cookie closet
and you just have to say why you need
the cookies I mean what like are there
some examples of ivory like I feel like
I need the cookie well I get is that a
good enough reason is it possible to say
I need the cookies today because I am
hungry for thin mints I need the cookies
because I cannot sit this close to a
cookie closet filled with cases of
cookies and
not eat at least one cookie like I am
only human yeah I I feel like you should
start out with the real reason right and
then you see it rap star so you start
out you say listen I would like to
access the cookie closet because I'm a
human being and I love cookies and then
if the the person who has the keys to
the cookie causes like I'm sorry that's
not a good enough reason I think you
come back the next day and you say well
I would like to access the cookie closet
today because I'd like to give some I'd
like to have some of the cookies for
myself but also to enjoy them with my
aunt who's going through a hard time it
doesn't matter if it's true or not and
then if that doesn't work then you've
got it like you've got to go deeper and
deeper into progressively crazier lies
until you're like I'm sorry I need to
access the cookies it is a matter of
national security
what like is what are the cookies tend
to be used for like I feel like if I'm
if I'm working on a Girl Scout Council
we got a cookie closet the cookie closet
is probably there for entertaining
guests because people are coming to
speak at the at the Girl Scout Council
or they're coming to write have a
meeting with you about marketing or
whatever there's you're like the people
coming to the Girl Scout Council are
expecting cookies because this is what
Girl Scouts are most known for
apparently and so you have to break out
the cookies for when guests come so you
need to be getting guests into the
office who are important to the Girl
Scout councils business and they'll go
and we're like our guest who is an
important person in the community right
and as a supporter of the Girl Scouts is
visiting we got to get some Tagalongs up
in here right right I mean I like that
idea to Hank because then the guest of
honor eats like two of the thin mints or
Tagalongs or whatever and then you're
like okay listen we don't want to just
let this sleeve of cookies rot Jon so I
have a good home for them my home John
yeah I have discovered something that
has I I thought I was crazy I thought I
was I thought I was broken and wrong and
that like my brain had made up made a
thing where there was no thing there are
two different companies that make Girl
Scout
keys there is what ABC Baker's and
there's little brownie bakers and well
and ABC and little brownie Baker's makes
Girl Scout cookies here in Missoula
there there where we get them from and
almost all of Florida also it's they
supply by far the most area of the
United States but ABC Baker's supplies
Orlando where we grew up and so when I'm
eating I've always like ever since I'm
going to Montana I've been like Thin
Mints are different they're just
different here and then I thought that I
was crypt but I'm not it's really a
thing they're different they're thin
mints in Montana are different from thin
mints in Orlando whoa Wow all of them
wow that's I mean so basically you're
saying I've got to look up where I am
Indianapolis you have wait where is
Indianapolis I think that all of Indiana
is is different from Indiana yeah yeah
so we've got the we've got the ones that
are not the Orlando thing correct you
have different thin mints and also well
I mean my my palate is not discerning
enough to have noticed but I would like
to congratulate you on that Tom and also
Orlando didn't even have Tagalongs
they're called peanut butter patties in
our land oh I think that they've
actually universally changed the name oh
okay
but regardless today's podcast is
brought to you by Orlando thin mints
Orlando thin mints not available in
Mizzou no no they're different I think
that I like the Orlando it's better John
this podcast is also brought to you by
John Green's car rat John Green's car
rat would like to know where we're going
today vodkas is an addition brought to
you by fog lightning fog lightning a
natural disaster I don't have to worry
about
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by that unknown vape juice smell
came out of someone's lungs and now I'm
really curious what it is good lord we
also have a real sponsor today and we'd
like to say a huge thank you to our
actual sponsor Backblaze so John you
know how like there's all this stuff on
your computer that's extraordinarily
important yes and you know how sometimes
hard drives just stop
working without any notice or like your
house get struck by lightning or like
someone steals your computer or any of a
number of or you leave it on an airplane
like I've never done that before I was
gonna say the most likely thing is that
you leave your your computer on an
airplane and never forgive yourself
that's that green story Oh
bad blaze exists to make this much less
of a worrying problem and they do it for
both Macs and PCs for $5 a month five
dollars a month is like how much you
spend on shampoo on coffee barely like
you barely been $5 a day on coffee some
people and it just it is such a huge
load off your mind to have this service
it's an incredible service it backs up
your documents your music your photos
your videos everything that you make
they have restored over 26 billion files
if you are worried and you should be
about losing the draft of your novel
which is an incessant worry of mine that
I've been freed from in the last three
months but whatever whatever you don't
want to lose you won't have to lose if
you just get back plays so go to
Backblaze dot-com slash dear John that's
Backblaze comm slash Dear John and sign
up for back plays and never have to
worry again about your files being
backed up and it's possible that you
could be one of those two like your
files could be one of those like the
file that you needed the picture your
kid or the draft of the thing or the
thing for your company it could be one
of the 26 billion files that backways
has recovered and if you go to back
please calm slash dear Hank you can get
you can go and you will get credit for
you checking out back plays which will
very much appreciate you can also
restore by mail so like if you're whole
system crashes and you like and you want
to get all your stuff instead of trying
to download all of it off of the
internet they'll actually send you a
drive and you can restore it from a hard
drive and if you send that hard drive
back to them it doesn't even cost you
anything extra so that's amazing back
please calm
slash Dear John backs please calm / to
your Hank they did they do both work hey
before we get to the all important news
for bars and AFC Wimbledon and thank you
again to back place for sponsoring
today's podcast before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want
to give you a few updates alright first
we have two Corrections from Caroline's
oh okay multiple Caroline's okay
different Caroline's Caroline writes
Dear John and Hank I'm not certain with
if the Fraulein qualifies as a
correction but in a recent episode of
the Pato listener wrote in wondering
about a hamsters ability to survive in
the wild imagine my severe
disappointment when both brothers failed
to mention the true name of the Syrian
hamster so the true name for the Syrian
hamster Hank the Arabic name literally
translated is mister saddlebags
[Laughter]
mr. saddlebags the are other correction
coming from Caroline Dear John and Hank
I'm a longtime listener and a big fan
but the most recent episode discussing
Benjamin Harrison has left me a little
bothered I volunteer as a docent at the
president Benjamin Harrison right and my
heart broke when Hank said that Harrison
might be at the end of the list of
presidents people remember I should also
add here Hank that I have many friends
who work at the Benjamin Harrison house
and I do not understand how I got into
this pickle I have heard from countless
people I know in real life who were
horrified by our complete failure to
reflect the many accomplishments of
president Benjamin Harrison to suggest
that he did hardly anything is a
disgrace to America's only Hoosier
President Caroline writes quick facts
include a huge expansion of America's
Navy creating America's second to fourth
national parks including Yosemite
attempts to protect the early
environment and early trust-busting
efforts including the McKinley tariff
and the Sherman Antitrust Act also John
Harrison was one of the less corrupt
presidents he actually shunned the
practice of appointing people to office
based off of pressures from his party
and instead made a point to appoint
those from all sides including
appointing some of the first African
Americans to political positions
Harrison is often overlooked because
there was no crisis to solve at the time
he wasn't involved in some awful
conspiracy and didn't raise America out
of disaster he kept the course steady
during his time in office especially
John but Hank as well you have to come
visit the president Benjamin Harrison
site to learn it's up it's in downtown
Indianapolis so it shouldn't be a
problem ask for Lucas he's my boss and
he's great well I'm I I now want very
very much be like hello I'm Hank I was
told to talk to Lucas I want to make
some kind of application that like type
in all the president's names you know
and then do some analysis to figure out
who the least-known president is is it
Chester Arthur is it Warren Harding is
it Rutherford B Hayes is it well
Caroline's argument is that regardless
of whether but Benjamin Harrison is a
lesser known president he shouldn't be
and as a Hoosier I should have called
you to town okay well and I apologize
stating a fact
is is different from agreeing that that
fact should be the way that it is and I
wasn't saying I think this person should
be the least well-known president whose
name I cannot remember at the particular
moment Harrison
some Harrison which Harrison is that I
think there were two of them okay
Henry Harrison was president right but
that's not who we're talking about who
are we talking about I because you're
digging a hole deeper and deeper I
there's a couple responses I also wanted
to get to including a response from
Molly who had to make the PowerPoint
further the guy Rick was retiring and it
was like her first day on the job and
she had to have a retirement PowerPoint
for a stranger Dear John and Hank just
as an update about the PowerPoint I was
able to scrape together some blurry
pictures including some of him with his
family I know and one of them holding a
baby elephant happened that his nickname
was Teflon Rick because nothing ever
sticks to him still I entirely convinced
that the guy I talked to wasn't messing
with me on that one it was a hiking
themed presentation about the next
adventure and the opening title was 12
years here Teflon Rick exclamation point
people seemed properly apathetic to the
whole thing while they ate their
barbeque
thanks for the read Molly oh yeah so
what why are people trying to stick
stuff to Rick I don't know I mean also I
don't know that being named teflon Rick
is good news I oh I hope Rick listens to
the plot and he writes in yeah we really
want to know why are people trying to
make things stick to you whether
actually physically or like the murder
rap or whatever like that the crime that
Rick may or may not have done I'm
confused
we've also got some information from
Sara who says dear brothers green since
y'all were talking about the illustrious
Indianapolis cemetery I thought we would
share the sign and the cemetery at the
town I grew up in it says thanks for
visiting come back when you can stay
longer grave sites available we'll put
that up on the patreon it's a pretty
great this is pretty great sign over at
patreon.com slash dear Hank Hank and
John last last last response we need to
get to Hank is from my Ally
you may remember it was a while back on
the pond yeah but somebody wrote in
saying that they were really struggling
with the male-dominated STEM program
that they were in and they wrote an
update nearly two years ago I sent an
email expressing my frustrations about
being in a male-dominated STEM program I
wanted advice on whether I should stay
or not but I stayed and it was the best
decision ever I just finished my first
year when I was getting ready to drop
out but I stayed deciding to see what
could come of the second year there were
new people in the second year and guess
who wasn't upset he spaghetti anymore
because there was a girl and we both
basically rule stem now I mean that
literally she's the president of our TSA
chapter and everyone in the engineering
program is in TSA and look I don't want
to explain the social hierarchy I don't
like long emails we just got out of
school stem certified - and not to throw
shade at the stem academics team but we
basically convinced a board of actual
adults that we knew what we were doing
with LCDs and I built a solar-powered
stoplight and my engineering teacher is
essentially my mother now on so many
things I love so many people staying was
the best decision I've made I mean that
was just a great email it made me so
happy so that's really wonderful John
yeah
any AFC Wimbledon dues for me how did
they play the MK Dons yeah does that
happened
Hank Hank yeah there is nothing Dawn's
about the franchise currently plying its
trade in Milton Keynes Sorry Sorry
oh my apologies you're welcome they did
they played the franchise currently
plying his trade in Milton Keynes it was
a I listened to it I watched the first
half on my eye follow-up I listened to
the second half on the radio w do n
hoping for a change in luck but alas it
was a nil nil draw right like the 88th
minute and E Bartram had a wonderful
opportunity to win the gun for AFC
Wimbledon but it wasn't to be it was a
you know look a point away from home is
not a disastrous result the problem is
that AFC Wimbledon are now 26 games into
their league one season and that means
there are only there only 20 games left
and we are currently sitting two points
adrift of safety so we have 28 points
the the milton keynes team and a couple
other teams have 29 or 30 and we are in
we need to we need to get up to 20th
place inc we just need to finish in 20th
and not get relegated so it's it's it's
getting there's 20 games left in the
season a lot can happen but I would be
lying if I didn't acknowledge that I was
getting nervous well do you feel like
you guys are kind of holding on there
it's not here at the bottom of the
bottom of the bottom got it it could be
worse it could be worse relegated as
that is do you make a lot less money
yeah also you just it's hard to get up
to the third tier right yeah you don't
want to get relegated because then you
have to try to get up again either
through direct promotion or through the
playoffs which is always a crapshoot if
we could just finish in 20th and then
keep keep one more season in Ligue 1 and
then we'll have our stadium built and
anything is possible so that's the
that's the news from AFC Wimbledon all
the games are big games now 20 games
left in the season
what's the news from Mars uh you know
how Mars has a lot of water on it it
turns out we've figured this out you
know a couple decades ago and I keep
finding new water in new places but one
of the things has always been a little
bit question a question e is how that
water exists so does it exist sort of in
like mineralized salts where it's not
really easy to get at or is it sort of
like just another piece of dirt so like
your dirt is part I sparked dirt which
is actually would be really hard like
kind of permafrost E you'd have to like
scoop it up and then melt the ice and
like then you'd have a bunch of mud and
you have to somehow get the dirt out and
either water out and so that's really
complicated movie there's a bunch of
rocks so you have like really rocky ice
chunks that this would be hard to work
with if you were on Mars and wanted to
get water so that's a lot of what we've
found is to sort of like just below the
surface there's a lot of little pieces
of ice mixed in with the dirt and that's
good it's nice to have any kind of water
but it it'd be a lot better if there was
like clean fresh not salty not mixed
with a bunch of dirt or rotted water and
so the recently a paper came out they
some researchers looked at saw with like
high-resolution artificial color images
they looked at images from the Mars
Reconnaissance Reconnaissance Orbiter
and we're able to identify in areas
where there had been like basically what
you would see like at the Grand Canyon
where you can see the layers of of like
sedimentary rock laid down yeah I think
we're able to identify layers where it
was just like a pure ice layer and we're
talking like tens of meters thick of
pure water ice with no rock inclusions
or anything and that's just like you
know it's but it's significantly below
the surface but it's on the order of
like reachable like meters down and and
so there is not just water on Mars but
there is also like like clean not mixed
with anything else water ice and that
the way that that happens is the same
way that it would happen on earth
which is snow would fall in the same
place year after year after year and
then that snow would get compressed and
it wouldn't evaporate or or melt or
anything will just keep getting
compressed until it became ice in the
way that a glacier would and then after
that sediments were laid down on top of
it probably through wind probably and so
there's a bunch of that and it's
indication both of like a lot of
precipitation on Mars but also good news
for people who want to go to Mars
someday and have clean water to drink
but also to convert into hydrogen and
oxygen for fuel but also to breathe so
that's a thing and it's real lots of
lots big slabs of clean water ice so I
was reading about this Hank because I've
become a little bit of a Mars fan I and
the thing that struck me reading about
it is that yes this is sweet clean water
ice but isn't it also really far away
from where humans would likely be if
they were going to go to Mars like
wooden humans probably live pretty close
to the equator and this is pretty far
from the equator yes where humans would
be actually is up for debate like
whether we would be close to the equator
because the weather is a little better
there maybe but like really weather part
like it probably isn't that big of a
deal like it's pretty cold and crappy on
Mars right because the weather is bad no
matter where you are so what's the
difference between super cold and super
cold that's a question I have to ask
myself every morning the the the the
much more interesting thing is like
versus how nice the weather would be is
how interesting it would be
scientifically so areas where there were
long standing pools of water lakes
oceans rivers things like that are
probably gonna be the places where we'll
be most known exploring it's interesting
interesting well good luck to you and
may it not be until 2028 so Hank thank
you for potting with me what have we
learned today
oh gosh John we learned that you cut you
oughta not litter
yeah we also learned that you can't you
can't keep a stolen base clarinet just
because you didn't steal it and we
learned that thin mints and thin mints
are different depending on where you
live and we learned that Hanks new book
truly is excellent oh thanks thanks John
and we also we also learned that men you
got to back your files up because it's
dangerous it's a dangerous world out
there
Thanks right ways that concert Dear John
back plays comm flash dear Hank thanks
again Hank thanks to everybody for
listening if you want to find out more
about our podcast or listen to our
weekly terrible podcast this week in
Ryan's you can do that over at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
thanks again to everybody for listening
Hank why don't you read the credits this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the theme music that you're
hearing right now and at the beginning
the podcast and at the beginning of this
week in Ryan's is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Applause]
[Music]